Science fiction is filled with tractor beams.
So real researchers have been working on making
that technology science fact.
And we’re getting closer with a new acoustic
tractor beam that has lifted the largest ever
object: a 2-cm ball!
In the movies, tractor beams are beams of
some undefined energy, but IRL that’s not
the case.
Commonly, researchers use sound.
The idea of harnessing sound waves for levitation
isn’t new.
Scientists have been exploiting the properties
of air and sound to this end for a while.
Remember that air is a fluid that behaves
like a liquid, even if we can’t see or feel
it the same way.
And sound is a physical vibration, even if
we don’t think of it as such.
Basically: harnessing acoustic power is harnessing
the lifting effect of physical sound waves
as they move through the air.
The sound compresses the air in waves and
those waves correspond to the sound’s wavelength.
Acoustic levitation uses this wave to balance
against gravity.
The result is a free-floating particle that
looks a little like science fiction magic.
Dialing in the sound waves means lifting objects
with extreme precision.
The thing is, it’s not exactly a technology
that’s easy to scale up.
Researchers have been struggling for years
to lift an object larger than the sound wave
they’re using.
Every time they try, the object spins because
the rotating sound field transfers motion.
Eventually, the object ends up flying out
of the sound wave.
But researchers have finally managed to control
this spinning motion by spinning the sound
wave instead.
Using ultrasonic waves at a frequency similar
to one that only bats can hear, they created
a vortex of sound that they twist to stabilize
the beam.
From there, they increased the size of the
silent core to where it was able to hold a
two-centimetre polystyrene sphere.
It’s tiny, but it’s two times larger than
the waves lifting it, making it the largest
object ever levitated with sound.
So, yes, the object is still tiny, but the
implications are huge.
Relatively speaking.
The researchers are looking ahead to using
very deliberately directed tractor beams to
move kidney stones through the body or direct
a capsule of pharmaceuticals to a target area.
So, it might be a while before we’re lifting
humans, but the upside is medical advances
will be great until then.
Thanks so much for watching, guys, and be
sure to subscribe for more Seeker.
Speaking of medical advances, what if one
shot could give you all your vaccines?
Trace has more on that, right here.
But on tractor beams, if you think about how
this works, it can’t happen in space.
Without air there’s no soundwaves.
We’ll have to harness some other energy
for our sci-fi needs.